I'm Dave Rubin and today I've been given
all of the flavors of prime that's right
these are all the flavors we've got
everything yes I'm told these are all
the flavors of prime I have never had
prime before until a minute ago we shot
another video where I had one gulp of
red that's it I'm going to order by the
best flavor of the worst flavor the
prime drink which I guess the kids are
all drinking the prime drink they're up
all night on the PlayStation play video
games how did they think that was okay
to even put it in the game drinking
Prime writing racist things
so I'm gonna taste each one and then
we've got nine of them here and then I
will order them accordingly first up
we've got the lemonade
that's not bad that's pretty good
actually that's pretty good I'm gonna
put that at number three I'm gonna
assume that two of these will be better
than that and I do like I do like lemon
and lime drinks generally speaking
I don't like it as much as the lemonade
but it's not bad we're gonna put that as
number five blue raspberry now when I
was a Gatorade guy I always like the
blue so I'm afraid I just blew myself
oh man that's like right out of a snow
cone right there
that's pretty solid we're going number
two on that one now we've got the meta
Moon
which I don't know what what kind of
flavor meta Moon
I don't even know how to describe that
flavor
that's an undescribable flavor
directly from the Moon
I'm Gonna Bump the orange at five
but it was a little bit better than the
orange so I'm gonna go five with the
metamoon now we got the the great people
like the purple drank it's a good drink
to me
[Music]
never really liked it back in Camp
they're always trying to push that on
you oh and this one time at band camp
never was interested I'm gonna put that
in at an eight no it's not my thing now
we've got the uh the tropical punch I
think this is the one I tasted earlier
yeah that's just a solid that's a solid
energy drink
approved I'm gonna put that
in front of number four here
did I do this already lemon lime oh and
I'm a lemon lime guy
it's not bad that's not bad put that in
front of the orange
and I'm gonna try this crazy thing
what's this here ice pop this is the one
that I bought from the kid on the street
I did a drug deal you got it you got
anymore that's that's pretty good
I could see this one being like an
All-Star one for the kids uh
that's pretty good
there's a theme in my energy drink thing
like I like like the the ice pop the
yeah that icicle thing
how am I feeling better oh I didn't
drink this one what do we got here
strawberry watermelon
wow
that's a little underwelding a little
underwhelming
I did like it more than the grape
you know this Moon one let me try the
moon one one more time
the blue one's growing on me because
it's like what the hell is it and where
did they get those ingredients from the
Moon I think we're gonna move the moon
one up
I think Moon's going three
red
I feel pretty good about this we're
locking it in
yes so number one is blue raspberry let
me just try the blue and the ice pop one
more time let's just confirm that number
one
yeah that's just a solid energy drink
right there
pretty good
let's move one more time
you know this Moon drink might be better
than the other two in a way because it's
not as it's not as powerful
it's giving you what you need
I'm gonna do something crazy here
I'm gonna do something crazy
we got Moon number one we got ice pop
number two we got blue raspberry number
three
that's it that's it
and now I have diabetes diabetes
goodbye